[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the road - mm I am your
host Caleb envy and as always you know
we're gonna be making a few pit stops on
this term - mm a lot of you may know
that I have an upcoming match with
Jonathan France starting April 12th we
just released a little preview for it it
was pretty exciting stuff if you haven't
seen that video yet I would definitely
recommend checking it out we had a lot
of fun doing it
but some of you may know we've been
billing the match as you know a strong
expert-level match but so that might be
a little bit misleading because actually
the average rating I think is somewhere
over 2,000 but Jonathan actually hasn't
quite gotten there yet so we're gonna
see if we can help him out today give
him a little a few tips a few tricks see
what he needs in order to get to that
2,000 level because you know I want this
match to be competitive for you guys so
we'll see what we can do here so that's
what we're gonna be doing today we're
gonna be taking a look at some of
Jonathan's recent games some of his
games from Leach s one of his games from
a recent staff tournament that we had
against Tony rich who is our club
director so let's start out with one
that happened online just a couple weeks
ago
zopi is actually Jonathan's internet use
your name so that's why it doesn't say
Jonathan down here but let's take a look
at what happened
so Jonathan had black he was playing
transversal well who is 2100 online and
his opponent played efore Jonathan
recently has been trying out this
Sicilian c5 stuff which is totally fine
Knight f3 d6
and g3 knight c6 Bishop g2 g6 so already
uh this is a little bit abnormal for a
lot of openings right you usually don't
see a player making this many weaknesses
right moving both of these pawns to the
light squares causes a lot of
dark-squared weaknesses which is you
know gonna be okay for black in this
line specifically as long as he's
careful about it but that's um
to keep in mind in your games is even
when you know you're allowed to break a
certain principle because it follows a
line you just have to be extra cautious
to be sure you know what you're doing
because otherwise you know making
weaknesses like this it's going to lead
to some tactics to some misfortunes that
can go wrong for you later on but like I
said totally fine for black still white
plays d4 so what do you think White's
intending to do here in the next couple
turns what are some features of this
position that have already kind of shown
themselves yeah so what does white want
to do what's he saying with d4
that's exactly right he wants to open up
the center so if you take a look white
already has these two pieces developed
right and black has only developed this
night and moved these three pawns up as
well so a couple things have been made a
parent already you know white has the
slightly development he can very
importantly castle in just one turn or
as it's going to take black many turns
to castle and he even has slightly more
control over the center slightly more
central space whereas black is really
only fighting for these two squares and
maybe the d5 square with this east six
move so as black you see all these
things happen and so what do you say to
yourself what what do you think you need
to do do you should you just continue
moving like normal and let what what
white maybe open up the center or should
you try to shut it down somehow
so yeah that's an interesting way to try
to keep the center closed as to play
this move c4 but the problem is you're
kind of giving white even more time to
increases lead right so you've made four
pawn moves now and white might simply
just Castle white might play something
like Queen e2 gaining more time on this
pawn and yeah you're gonna fall further
behind in development and you've kept
the center closed for the moment but
this d5 move might come soon and that
might cause some problems cuz then you
know these two pieces are gonna be
attacked it's gonna be tough to keep
things closed so any other ideas c4 was
interesting
it's the three of them were yes
any other ideas for black
so there are two things you can try you
can try to fight back in the center
fight back for some central squares or
you can kind of give up some central
squares maybe but you know slow down
White's plan and you know have easy
development for your pieces so you know
what are some other ways to try that
just throw out some moves they don't
have they don't have to be right yeah so
pawn b6 is another interesting move
aiming to you know develop this bishop
right yeah and it does add another
defender to this pawn so while this is
interesting it gives you know this
Bishop an avenue to develop it's making
slightly more weaknesses right you see
White's Bishop is kind of lurking way
behind the scenes here behind this night
behind this pawn but later on it might
cause some issues along this diagonal
and the other thing that you really
gotta look out for it doesn't help you
get Castle Denny sooner right your King
is still gonna be stuck in the center
for a while as far as what might white
might do he might just again ignore this
he might play something like c3 maybe
just castle maybe again this d5 break
could be interesting so suppose I might
have thought of would be something like
Bishop g7 would be kind of interesting
right
you're fighting back in the center and
you're developing a piece you know maybe
you're hanging this pawn but I thought
it might be an interesting sacrifice
maybe later on you can play Queen a5 to
try to pick this one up but then the
next thought that occurred to me was why
even allow white to take this pawn like
this maybe black can just capture this
pawn right so if you were to take here
maybe Knight takes and now after Bishop
g7 you're developing with tempo right
you're not giving white time to open up
the center and you're developing your
pieces as quickly as you can
another important thing to note here is
you've actually traded off a C pawn for
a deep on so the reason that's important
is because Center pawns tend to be worth
a little bit more than that wing pawns
especially if you can push them to
advance squares so that's another kind
of advantage black would be gaining here
but that's you know
definitely not to say that that white
would be any worse here in any way so if
I were black I might have tried
something like C takes D I'm going to
try something like Bishop g7 the other
move black Canary here was actually d5
which was an interesting way to fight
back for some of these central squares
that White's trying to take over
instead what black did what Jonathan did
in this case was d6
so in my opinion this was kind of
missing the point right so what do you
think is wrong with d6 first of all you
should ask yourself what is my move
doing so what does d6 trying to
accomplish he's protecting this pawn but
you know I mean the pawn was already
kind of protected
see it's not doing a whole lot right
it's giving this bishop a square which
you know is as convenient it's which
also might be used to help block up this
Center for a while but so it's it's
simply too slow so how can you take
advantage of this already with the white
pieces the slightly suboptimal move yeah
exactly you just take this pawn you open
it up and then you trade Queens and now
all of Plex pieces are on the back row
and you've got you know a huge lead in
development so how might you consider
continue here with white now what do you
think the next step would be I'm not
sure I follow
I guess so B 1 2 C 3 in this case but
yeah you're exactly right so you're
actually already aiming at some awkward
squares for black so what is white kind
of threatening to do next if black isn't
careful using this Knight specifically
yeah night b5 coming into c7 attacking
these weak squares so like we said you
know these two pawn moves they didn't
actually weaken the Queen sight so much
but they did make a lot of weaknesses
all around blacks camp the way Black has
played this entire opening so because
black is underdeveloped and he has all
these weaknesses white can already kind
of aim for some nasty stuff so this
would have been nice to see from white
white actually went a different path and
played Knight to c3 first and Jonathon
again kind of needed to realize that you
know things were going kind of insane
like really wrong for him already and
said he just kind of played the slightly
optimistic Bishop g7 and now white did
take this opportunity to play the right
move
do you take c5 d c5 Queen D 898 and
already we can see Knight b5 as
threatens you know White has three
pieces developed Black has one piece
develops and his King is stuck in the
center so we saw Knight b5 from white
and now a black tried King to f8 to save
the material white simply continued with
Bishop before a very strong move again
just developing your last piece and you
know creating more threats so this game
is already you know black is already
completely losing so the really key
mistake was this move d6 in the second
move Bishop g7 so the lesson I kind of
want to take out of this game which
we're gonna keep going through it and
see how it ended up because he had a lot
of chances to to come back when they
maybe not a lot but some but the lesson
to take away was when you're unfamiliar
with the opening and you noticed you're
kind of breaking some principles right
so the first thing you do when you're
unfamiliar with an opening is you want
to fall back on principles and so since
black didn't do that here he had to be
very cautious very aware of what was
going on and needed to really stay alert
and and realize he might already be in
serious trouble he might already need to
do something kind of drastic with that
being said the game's not over yet
Jonathan went for a six giving his rook
the key a seven square after Knight
see seven of course we're all it rooks
belong is stuck on a seven behind two
pawns we saw castles Queen inside from
white another strong move getting
another piece into the game Jonathan
knight c6 to save his night we saw a
Bishop d6 check tonight G to e7 and now
Bishop takes c5 so White has already
kind of one upon using his well-placed
pieces we saw b6 from black and now what
do you think white should do here after
b6 v6 was actually a nice try so yeah
your first instinct is to just take it
right but maybe black has some tricks up
his sleeve if you take on b6 what do you
think black might try
yeah rook b7 attacking both of these
pieces and so that's something to be
aware of so I've talked about this in a
previous lecture but tactics show up
when there are loose pieces when there
are undefended pieces and so definitely
these two pieces are loose and under
defended so after something like Bishop
d6 we would see rook b7 and now there's
really no way to say both of these
pieces you might try Knight to it but
now is there anything for black here
Knight a it's obviously not a pleasant
move to play
well work v8 is actually better than
repeating you came from a s7 right and
now you've gone to b8 so this is
attacking both pieces and now there is
no way to defend both of them I can try
something like e 5 trying to open up
this diagonal but it's simply not in
time well I can just capture this night
and of course if night back to c7 this
bishop is now hanging that's the key
difference so because of that what
should white play after b6
it's a very direct move it's not very
tricky at all it's just defending the
knight in the bishop Bishop takes Knight
is another interesting try the problem
is this Knight is actually short on
squares know where to go right so the
best you could do is maybe taking a pawn
on your way out somehow I'm not even
sure what she would be yeah ninety five
would be interesting but you did end up
losing this this piece here so
definitely not ideal maybe night before
so better than Bishop e7
any ideas how can we defend this night
not pitch up takes me six no Bishop e7
simply Bishop d6 and there's no way to
attack this guy again there's actually
no way to attack this guy again cuz like
I said blacks pieces are awkward he
doesn't have a lot of space and he's not
developed so Bishop d6 would have been
easily winning for for white white would
then probably continue with something
like e 5 opening up this to this Bishop
on this diagonal and things would be
nice but in the game white actually fell
for it he actually took on b6 and
Jonathan played rook b7 white played
Knight a 8 and then Jonathan played f6
so this was very strange to see right
but this is actually not a completely
uncommon thing to see in a games around
this level is people try to try to do a
trick and then uh you know they get like
halfway through it they're like oh I
guess maybe it's not working but the
thing is you really really have to have
alarm bells going off in your head when
you get to a position like this when you
see pieces placed on such really absurd
squares that they shouldn't be on and so
under defended like these both of these
pieces like have nowhere to go and so
there has to be a tactic there there
almost has to be it's kind of crazy if
there isn't so that's when you really
need to take your time spend your time
on this move find the best move so yeah
we went over it a second ago it's just
rook to b8 attacking both pieces
yeah and if the knight moves we can take
this bishop if the bishop trace are in a
way obviously we can take this Knight so
there's just nothing for wait to do and
black would actually probably be maybe
slightly better and that being said f6
here and now this was really kind of the
end of the game white simply extracts
his Bishop and extracts his Knight and
there's not much left for a for black
try all right we see Knight take C it
happened it rook takes c8 this is a good
idea from from white simply trading off
Black's piece which was threatening to
activate for his piece which like we
said it looks in Iceland b6 but maybe
it's slightly overextended maybe it's
going to be the victim of some tactics
if White's not careful we see Bishop
take c7 again White's just trying to
trade down which is totally fine King me
7 c3 Knight a5 Bishop f19 c4 so this
move is a little bit strange from
Jonathan you know you never want to
trade down when you're behind a material
especially in an online game like this
where anything can kind of happen so I
thought it would have made a lot more
sense just to play rugby 6 just to be a
practical player keep this night on the
board aimed kind of at this Kings side
here but instead we saw a nice c4 and
this simply brings white closer to an
easier end game to win
rook e1 King e6 I'll just play through
these moves because they don't matter as
much and now we reached this position so
just off the top of your head what do
you think are some you know potential
tactics here this is another way to kind
of recognize tactics is to notice the
placement of pieces and to use those
patterns that you've seen before to
recognize some tactics that are
potential you know they they don't work
just yet
but maybe someday down the road you
should keep your eye out for something
like this happening it's kind of a vague
description I gave but which of these
pieces look like you know there might be
one through some kind of basic tactic
that we know either a pin
some kind of double attack some kind of
I don't know skewer do any of those ring
a bell here with the way blacks pieces
are placed so yeah he might not have a
tactic yet but we're looking for
potential tactics in the position yeah
that's exactly right black should notice
hey these two pieces are kind of lined
up awkwardly right I've seen this
pattern before the Knights threatening
to come into c5 so that's something to
be aware of in your games there are many
ways to find tactics in your games to
recognize tactics but noticing when your
pieces are kind of awkwardly placed is a
big part of it so I would have looked to
see move like Herc to c7 here simply
adding a defender to the square stepping
out of this potential fork you're
stepping into of course another
potential fork if a knight ritalin them
d5 but of course the knight you know
it's pretty far away from hitting that
square instead Jonathan played this move
which of course now what can white play
what's the finishing blow here
yeah that's exactly right just removing
this defender of the c5 square and then
this fork ends the game right my twins a
piece to go what the two pawns he was
already up so a lot of things went wrong
for Johnathan this game right
so to recap he was unfamiliar with the
opening which sometimes that just
happens in chests you're not going to
know every opening all the time but
that's when you need to fall back on
opening principles right you don't want
to be playing these unnatural looking
moves if you're really not sure what's
going on with making weaknesses and not
developing your pieces just kind of
pushing pushing a lot of pawns and not
getting develops that's mistake number
one
let's see mistake number two was I mean
not being prepared for the center to
open up that kind of goes with what I
was saying so let's see we're here in
this game now with d6 and Bishop g7
that's kind of where he was actually in
a losing position and then allowing all
this he was kind of forced into it
actually by his opening choices but then
especially here he did well to find b6 a
clever way to take advantage of whites 2
under defended pieces but then not
realizing that he should have a tactic
here and taking his time to find the
tactic that was kind of mistake number
two I think mistake number 3 which was
hard to avoid was letting all these
pieces get traded off and the mistake
number 4 was playing of course this
Bishop d6 move but more specifically not
being aware of the potential tactics in
the position and so this is kind of
critical not only when you're in a
losing position but when you're in a
winning any type of position you have to
be aware of the potential tactics even
if they don't work yet they might work
later so you got to be on the lookout
for those
mm-hmm so yeah that's the move I
suggested was this ruckus e7 move
stepping out of this fork and keeping an
eye on this potential square for the
night to move up to so definitely a lot
of things for Jonathan to work on there
so if you're watching Jonathan take a
look at some of these ideas maybe it'll
help you improve a little bit before our
mesh and that being said though we can't
be too hard on the guy this was an
Internet game so let's look at a game he
played where he was fighting hard he was
tied for first place this was actually
the chess club staff championship it's
not the most recent one we had but it is
the one where you played the toughest
competition in tony rich who helps
organize all of our big events big US
Championship events and you know helps
to run the club
Tony's no slouch he's over 2,000 I think
so he doesn't need this class but we're
gonna be taking a look at what separated
him from Jonathan in this game so this
was a USCF Retd event Jonathan was
giving it as all I think he was fighting
for a big prize like a comp day or
something so definitely something he
cares about
so definitely no excuses here he was
giving it his all but let's see what
still went wrong for him we saw a d4 c4
d5 and this is a Benko gambit so this is
all theory which I'm sure Jonathan and
Tony both knew
let me just reach kind of the starting
tab yeah here so after Queen b6 we kind
of find the you know the first real
place where white can branch off in this
a4 line specifically in the Benko so how
many of you are familiar with the Bunco
gambit know a little bit about it yep so
what's the basic idea so of course white
is up upon here if you do a quick count
but what does black get in exchange for
it
so what type of positional advantage
yeah it's these queenside files
that's where black gets his play from
right White's up upon but he's going to
find it hard to use his extra pawn as is
on the side of the board and blacks
pieces are all gonna be kind of placed
to try and attack these pawns try and
break through and win them back so
that's kind of the type of game you
should be expecting in the Benko gambit
which I'm sure Jonathan was aware of he
used less than thirty Seconds to get to
this position thanks to the wonder of
dgt boards we have all this info we saw
rook to a3 so this isn't actually the
main line I'm not sure if Jonathan had
this special line prepped for this match
or not but it is a perfectly fine move
what do you think the idea is first off
it looks kind of strange right it's not
a normal opening move that you would see
oh yeah so it protects this night and
the idea is that you want to advance
this pawn but protecting this night
wasn't what white needed to do to
advance the pawn actually so the idea is
more it gets the stroke on a safer
Square so one common tactic that you
find in the Banco gambit let's just play
some moves here and let's say Y it plays
like rook e1 here for some reason a lot
of these were nonsense moves but don't
worry about it but one common tactic is
there has a pin on this a pawn and white
wants to put his knight on b5 but
sometimes he falls victim to this type
of tactic right so that's one advantage
of putting the rook on a3 is after
something like ninety five the rook is
defended a big second advantage to this
is it steps off this diagonal of this
bishop okay so we've seen this before
when you suggested b6 in the first game
you might fall victim to some tactics
because these sneaky bishops that get
fianchettoed they can often come to life
and attack things you know that are
hidden along the diagonal turkey threes
a kind of a multi-purpose move
we saw rook b8 from black which makes a
lot of sense he's playing simply putting
his rooks on the open files Queen c2
from white stepping off the back rank
defending this pawn defending this pawn
defending this Knight a very decent move
Queen to b4 activating his Queen we see
York to e1 adding another defender to
this weak pawn Knight g4 so of course
the idea here is he wants to reroute
this Knight to e5 and aim at some
critical squares in White's camp and now
we see Knight b5 the move white has been
trying to play it helps kind of block
off these these two rooks here by
shoving this Knight in the way it also
aims at some slightly uncomfortable
squares for black if he's not careful we
saw Knight b6 aiming at this pawn also
aiming at this square b3
and now what do you think blacks should
play it what does black been playing for
cuz if he's not careful a Bishop d2
moved what will come in a quite handy
for white and it's gonna hurt black
quite a lot when he figures out this
this Queen has no squares so you want to
solve this problem and find a way to
break down these pawns so you can
continue attacking them
so someone in the YouTube chat is
wondering if the 12a for variation so
this variation is still considered
vetted for right and I think the latest
I've heard is that this is really the
line that makes black players
uncomfortable when playing the Benko is
this a for stuff so I'm not sure if it's
objectively better still but it does
give black some discomfort but yeah so
any ideas from you guys for black what
moves were you thinking about
you got anything yeah well yes so 9 a4
unfortunately this move isn't quite
playable because this pawn does come
back to defend this Knight and again
because of this nicer k3 move this line
wouldn't actually be great for black
because we have this Bishop to defender
stuff and at the end of the day we end
up up in exchange so again that Rick a3
move coming in handy against these
tactics with this bishop being nicely
placed but that was a good idea you
definitely want to weaken these two
pawns somehow so yeah c4 is the right
idea I see some people in the youtube
check out it so c4 trying to break down
these pawns so now how do we want to
respond to this as white as white you
see you know I'm definitely in some
danger here he's he's really breaking
down my stuff what can I do there are a
few options for white
see a bishop t2 is a good move it's what
Jonathan actually played in the game but
the thing you have to realize which
obviously it's it's difficult when
you're just attending a lecture to do
this but in and over the board game
where you're you know you're fighting
hard you definitely want this this comp
day you know you're fighting your boss
you want to beat them beat them up in
this chess game what you do when you
enter Bishop d2 this is something you
should realize as you enter a tactical
variation right so what I mean by that
is black has attacked one of your pieces
he's threatened to take it and what
you've done is not like resolve the
situation what you've done is made the
situation more complicated by putting
one of blacks pieces under attack but
not protecting your own so what you do
when you enter a variation like this is
you've got to calculate through to the
end so what do you think I mean by the
end where does a tactical variation end
if it starts when you know pieces are
under attack
sorry what was that so yeah see that one
move after you finish exchanging pieces
is a it's a good way to put it it's not
quite the phrasing I would have used
what I did did you have in mind when you
stop exchanging pieces okay so the way I
like to put it is the line is over when
no threats are being made anymore so
what do I mean by that so let's say you
know this is a threat and this is a
threat so let's say black were to play
Queen c5 here white we're to take here
black were to take here all right I move
out of the way we're not quite done yet
because this is still a threat so we
have to think about this move and we
have to think about one more move for
black if he has any more threats here
for example green f2 I missed which is a
problem so okay so let's like when c5
now White has to deal with this threat
so let's say Bishop f4 and then let's
say the line continues takes takes okay
I keep blundering see things are hard so
you have to be thinking about all these
all these lines but alright let's say C
takes b3 happens Bishop takes b4 happens
B takes c2 happens now black still has a
threat so you have to find a move for
white here and you can't do it right so
this line wouldn't work but you see how
things are suddenly becoming very
concrete so that's why you have to think
all the way through to the end before
you enter a tactical variation so what
happened in the game was black played
the most natural move C takes B 3 so we
just saw the bishop takes b4 isn't a
very good move I went through that
pretty quickly but definitely not a
great move because black can take here
in advance this pawn further up the
board so what do you think white wants
to do instead any ideas
see this move isn't so good because you
have this thread on this pawn and this
pawn has survived and Bishop b2 is
threatens queening is gonna be happening
so you don't like that line is white but
you've had to see this coming in your
head from Bishop d2 right because you've
entered the variation there's no turning
back
rook b1 it's gonna be a similar
situation now you can take this back
with the rook if you want but I don't
see it there's a knight takes a four
maybe it could be problematic or it
takes a four so you want to move the
Queen well where do you move the Queen
oh not quite b2 b1 Saul right so you see
this line in your head you see okay
Bishop d2 C takes b3 Queen b1 do you
stop calculating there or is there still
more to do there's more to calculate
right because you still have threats in
the position so let's try to do this in
our head now without putting it on the
board so Bishop d2 c takes b3 Queen to
be 1 black has to move as Queen so where
does black move the Queen or deal with
the threat not necessarily move the
Queen c5 I think I heard so yet the
black Queen goes to c5 are you done
calculating now or is there more to
calculate yeah now we see this idea
where the Queen is attacking f2 so
there's still more to calculate so how
do we want to deal with throughout on f2
after Queen B 1 queen c5 is there a
convenient way
so you can play rookie too but then
again we run into the same problem right
where black still has threats he still
has threats an a4 as well so we need to
find some way to not allow all these
threats and our calculations so Bishop
d2 C takes b3 we need to put our Queen
somewhere that kind of stops all these
threats from from the black side so
what's been the big problem and a lot of
these lines what does white had to kind
of deal with uncomfortably
the rook on a8 so yet this a for pawn
has been a problem but what's been the
other problem spend this Queen on c5
right attacking this f2 pond it's kind
of been granting black this extra tempo
that we need to kind of consolidate our
position so we want to find some way to
stop this Queen from getting to F
getting to f2
so let's put this on the board so how
can we stop this Queen from attacking f2
other than taking it because we've seen
that taking it doesn't quite work we
need an extra tempo somehow
so yeah the people in the YouTube chat
have some good ideas would you say so
Rokeby 3 is a good idea maybe Queen
takes a four and so yeah we had even
material now but this would definitely
be better than a I think what we were
looking at a second ago especially with
some Knights e7 stuff this is an
interesting idea maybe there's some
problems involving a let's see yeah
maybe Queen York b3 is isn't isn't a
terrible idea yeah rook be threw in
Queen b3 I think are both fine for white
there's one other idea though which I
want to take from the YouTube chat this
was the line that appealed to me the
most which is Queen c6 and so now the
idea is you are still attacking this
Queen so black is something to deal with
the c5 is still the only square but now
you can deal with this threat with tempo
by capturing the Queen and then
capturing on b3 so this is the way I I
might have tried to deal with it if I
were playing and Jonathan shoes we still
lose this pawn but now we've given black
this weakness and this pin isn't so so
relevant because we can break the pinion
with there could be one
maybe if c4 let me see this Rick before
idea and it would just be an endgame now
where I think I would slightly prefer
white because I think you know this pawn
is gonna end up being a weakness rather
than the strength on c4 with that in
minds
the point of this all which was you know
to kind of introduce you to calculating
calculating is one of the hardest parts
of chests calculating correctly is even
harder but the way you want to do it is
you want to go through to the end until
there's no more threats and evaluate
there so you can't evaluate this
position there's no evaluation you can
give to this position cuz things are
still hanging things still have to be
moved you don't know what's gonna happen
you have to get to the position where
you know there's like you're no more
threats or your opponent has too many
threats for you to deal with so that can
be tough and over the board games but
it's definitely
how you need to approach calculating is
okay I need to get to the end of the
line and so what I would recommend to
Jonathan is to start doing that in his
games because he played Queen to d1
which runs into a similar problem after
Queen to c5 now he simply has to deal
with this threat on this f2 pawn so he
plays Queen to e2 but now he hasn't had
time to recapture this be pawn and after
pawn to be two it's actually going to be
sticking around for a while with the
support of this Bishop and so already
Wyatt is actually completely lost here
this b2 pawn is simply too strong the
game continued with h3 kicking this
night away from this f2 pawn Knight to
c4 so again another Intermezzo here I
work to be 395 and this part of the game
isn't as relevant although I did want to
mention something here so we talked
about this briefly in the first game but
it's about putting up resistance when
you're losing so let's say you're
playing is black or playing yeah playing
is black would you rather play against
the guy who goes 95 Bishop e5 Bishop c3
Bishop takes c3 rook takes c3 or would
you rather play against the guy who goes
Knight to d4
and let's not go any further just
against the guy who trades off two sets
of pieces or yes a guy who doesn't who
do you want to be playing against if you
have black hair that's option number one
option number two
yeah you'd rather be pulling against
this right you know more pieces are off
the board there's less for you to worry
about
so yeah it's difficult to come up with a
winning plan or to you know conclusively
end the game to you know stop all
counterplay end the game when there's a
lot of pieces on the board right when
your opponent has more pieces than he
has more chances to create his own
threats whereas the more pieces that get
taken off the board the less chances to
create threats he has so that's actually
a pretty huge mistake from Jonathan here
is trading off these two sets of pieces
something like Knight to d4 poses
actually a lot more problems for for
blacks to deal with it keeps things
complicated for example game might have
continued something like let's see here
so in my analysis actually threw in
Bishop b4 which is another interesting
move forces this Queen away so Queen b6
and now Knight to d4 and let's see how
the game might have continued something
like grep takes a four makes a lot of
sense right picking up a free pawn
bishop c3 makes a lot of sense for white
putting this rook opposite this Queen
already we see more threats being
created so the Queen might have to move
again we see rip to be one now and after
something like Knight to d7
already white is picking up this pawn
and at the end of the day the tactics
work out slightly in blacks favor and he
gets to pick up this efore pawn but this
is definitely an interesting endgame
that y can definitely try to hold by no
means is white completely lost here
whereas we can see what happens in the
game later on but the point I'm trying
to prove is you can just create a lot of
annoying threats for what to deal with
and then it might seem counterintuitive
that to say oh you can't trade here but
you can trade here but the difference is
you know White's getting something in
return for it now
white held off on the trade but in
return he gets to pick up the strong
pawn on b2 so that's what I'm saying is
keep pieces on the board until you can
you know prove something or if you can't
prove something then just try to keep
creating threats what that being said
what happened in the game was of course
Knight takes e5
and this trade on c3 and after work a
four night a three or take say three
more pieces coming off the board
and thus Queen B five move was actually
slightly inaccurate from Tony because it
does allowed this slightly awkward check
and now you know black has had to waste
some time dealing with this check better
would have been just Queen to b6 when
right away
this is threatened and there's really
nothing uh nothing white can try to do
about it after something like let's see
probably just Roque one here this would
just be game over but you know we saw it
Queen B fire from Tony which allows this
check now of course you can't capture it
because of Queen takes Queen so we see a
King g7 takes takes rook b1 and now
Jonathan is stuck trying to hold this
end game with this pawn on b2 rather
than this other endgame that we saw
where okay blacks up upon but his extra
pawns on e7 right I would much rather
play that on game than the Sun again
so I mean White's just completely losing
here I'll play through the gate through
the moves this h4 move is a slight
inaccuracy which it probably didn't
affect the outcome of this game but when
you're trying to hold like this you tend
to not want to make any more weaknesses
especially in a major piece endgame like
this so h4 is just giving up slightly
more squares to the opponent so
definitely not something you want to do
from the black side h5 actually makes
slightly more sense I don't wanna go
into too many details about this endgame
which is clearly just winning for your
black but we see king h2 now and both
players kind of just make time for a
second unfortunately for Jonathan he
makes time in a way that loses
so again just being aware of potential
tactics in the position noticing the
fact that this Queen is staring down
this diagonal and not stepping into the
pin which is tough to do especially when
you're dead lost like this and you know
you're dead lost and we just kind of
want to end the game but it it's key to
putting up a good fight as staying in
the game really thinking about it so
after this the game ended pretty quickly
here
we saw you six finally breaking open
this this diagonal and after this black
shirt into a winning your endgame which
was eventually won believe it or not
just push this phones up the board and
here Jonathan resigned so that's already
been a lot we've gone over but so what
are some key points that I've made try
to refresh them in your head so I
calculate to the end and the end means
when there are no more obvious threats
in the position or even subtle threats
you don't want those either yeah try to
create more threats keep more pieces on
like these are things I'm sure Jonathan
has heard before but the other part of
it which I'll get into a bit later is
you know applying them at the board but
so okay so keeping pieces on the board
to create more threats I'm ready if you
didn't calculate through to the ends in
this first game especially when you're
unfamiliar with the opening you want to
fall back on principles you don't want
to make a lot of weaknesses let's see
yeah a lot of weaknesses with stuff like
this and not developing your pieces
later on in this game we saw you know
noticing when pieces are under defended
or overextended which I tell the whole
lecture on this
that's when tactics show up that's when
you really need to look for tactics so
when Jonathan should have found this
Rick be it and then yet lastly noticing
when pieces are awkwardly placed to step
into tactics these are all things that
Jonathan is doing wrong in these games
and some of them are you know popping up
more frequently but what I want to talk
about which is what I think Jonathan's
problem is which is what I think a lot
of players problem is I think everybody
struggles with this it has to deal with
this guys use your name lazy youth so
what happens to a lot of players is
laziness it's a lot of problem it's a
big problem it's a huge problem that
people face and what do I mean by that I
don't mean not wanting to study not
wanting to come out to classes
I mean when you're actually sitting
there at the board playing the game you
get lazy
it just happens right you're there for
hours and hours and hours and you get
bored you get a little lazy and you're
like okay I know these principles I know
I should calculate through to the ends
but you just don't want to sometimes
right it's tough to do this on every
move to be saying okay okay where are my
pieces are they where they need to be
are there any tactics I'm missing all
right does this variation actually end
here it's just laziness that crops up
which is extremely difficult to combat
actually but it's just something the
only advice I can get for it is being
aware that it exists being aware when
you're doing it being aware okay wait I
didn't actually think about this move as
much as I should have you know it's
tough to apply that much mental effort
on every turn but it's something to keep
in mind that is a legitimate problem
that I think everyone deals with and
it's not something like to be ashamed
about it's not something low I'm lazy at
the board or anything it's something
that just it occurs and something you
have to keep in mind with that in mind
let's take a quick look at this last
game I think we still have some time
left so we saw a d4 d5 c4 c6 and it was
a Slav defense and so it transposed into
kind of an exchange slot here but it's
an exchange love where black has had two
fiing kettled this bishop so it's not an
ideal exchange love because this bishop
really doesn't want to be looking at
this Punk we see h3 from white giving
this bishop a square to retreat to
knight c6 we should be too excuse me b6
York c1 there should be seven castles
rook c8 Queen B 395 Queen a4
and some more moves and now Knight to c4
so this is the first big point I want to
talk to so what is going on in this
position first of all the first thing to
notice is you know both players are
well-developed
both players are castled the opening is
kind of over there's no real problems
there there's no huge pawn breaks that
either players threatening just yet so
it's going to be mostly about piece
placement and weaknesses so whose pieces
are placed better what do you think
white or black black what do you say
that
yep both players are kind of you know
they're controlling a lot of the board
it's kind of a full board game sure so
as far as King safety I'd say both Kings
are you know almost completely safe but
I would definitely say black has a very
safe King I think that's what you're
trying to say but as far as piece
placement I would actually prefer the
white pieces here and the reason for
that has to do with these two bishops
first of all this bishops staring at
this pawn which for the moment it's not
obvious what purpose is actually going
to serve besides maybe defending the
King but I think the King is already
pretty safe and then this bishop is kind
of staring at his own pawns you know
it's not doing much it is serving an
important purpose controlling this
square but that's kind of all it's doing
yeah if the board opens up though right
you have to find a way to open up the
board for those bishops to come to life
whereas for whites bishops you know this
Bishop is on a pretty nice diagonal it's
stuck behind this night but this Knights
pretty mobile right as places to go this
Bishop isn't great but it controls some
key squares here and it controls this
knight outpost as far as the major
pieces these are all pretty well evenly
matched I would say considering they're
all opposing each other in a symmetrical
pawn structure and then as far as the
Knights this Knight in this Knight are
kind of cancelling each other out right
this Knight wants to come to eat for
this Knight prevents it and then this
knight in this Knight so this knight on
c4 looks pretty strong right and it's
not any five looks pretty strong but the
thing is they're kind of in contact
right now so I would say you know the
Knights are also pretty pretty well
placed for both sides but there's a key
difference and the key difference comes
from the weaknesses both players have
made so what do you think are some
pretty key weak squares and blacks camp
the knight is occupying one of them on
e5 other key weaknesses
definitely the c5 square this is the
major weakness I want to talk about
because both of these pawns have been
pushed
so neither can ever control the c5
square right and you know black weight
eventually might play before to even
further solidify this but he hasn't as
of yet which is very very important for
White's position because this knight
looks very nice here but because white
hasn't made as many weaknesses he has an
extra option that black doesn't have so
what's that extra option the white has
here so yeah you can play 93 and let's
say I don't like makes them nothing move
but then the important thing is white
has an extra option now
so yeah he put it on c5 but black also
had this option White's extra option has
to deal with the weaknesses that he
hasn't yet made so he hasn't pushed this
pawn forward so he hasn't fully weakened
to the c-4 square so what can he do
yeah you can play b3 and then suddenly
this awesome Knight is running a little
short on squares it has to kind of
retreat right and now you know we see
maybe White's Knight come up and go to
this very excellent square putting
pressure on this weak bishop so this
would have been very nice for white is
using his advantage here as advantage
where he can come into this square but
he can still kick his opponent out of
this square that's actually kind of the
only advantage white has another
advantage that I did talk about is this
bishop being better than this bishop but
so that's kind of a very slight thing
the big big thing here is black doesn't
have b6 and white has b3 as someone in
the YouTube chat has said with that in
minds what do you think about this move
from white playing b3 right away
looks good so it's actually not my
favorite move it gives away a lot of
whites advantage what's the reason for
for that what does black have here
night b2
yeah tonight doesn't have many squares
right 93 is another option but this
night would also get kind of stuck over
here maybe just something like Queen to
d2 aiming for this Square and then
already this night's not actually doing
a whole lot on the side of the board so
yeah you can just take these nights off
the board right and this is what black
did in the game and now all of a sudden
yes you have control over this square
but now you've lost your piece that
you're going to put on that square so
the squares no longer really doing
anything for white there's no way to use
it which is why we had to play this
night d3 move that you Satya actually
suggested first off in order to aim at
this Square and prevent this Knight from
coming off the board so it's a very key
thing to recognize in your games is you
know when you haven't made these
weaknesses you definitely it that's
always a good thing but you definitely
need to have a way to use them so
Jonathan actually just gave up his way
to use this square here which kind of
gave away its advantage and all right at
this moment it's 654 so if you guys are
playing in the Knights I would recommend
heading over there and getting ready for
your game because you know don't wanna
be late but thank you guys for for
coming out I'm going to wrap up this
game in the next five minutes but so
yeah you guys are welcome to head over
if he wants okay moving on from there
though we saw 94 and I take c4 and more
piece trades whoops catch back up to the
game here
all right more peace trades and now
actually since there's no point to
controlling the square anymore
why it actually does just play before
giving up you know any any hope he had
of claiming an advantage and now black
plays e5 rook to d1 rook to DA rook to
c5 and this is actually already falling
into some danger because unfortunately
for Jonathan at the end of the day you
get into this end game and now like has
this nice move activating his rook
before activating white struck and he
will went upon and you know the game
continues like this and actually black
goes on to win this rockin game which
was a you know something else I could
talk about if I had more time but I
think we've covered quite a lot for
today and so I just want to do a quick
recap instead of going into the details
of this specific endgame so any
questions you had overall about anything
I was doing today you know all kind of
make some sense a lot of it was kind of
complicated stuff but see yeah what are
my tips for Jonathan overall I guess is
the question and so Jonathan if you're
watching this if you're listening I
would definitely say you know when you
do find yourself in unfamiliar territory
in the opening which doesn't happen to a
guy like you very often because you know
he's of chess openings explained
explained fame but when it does happen
you definitely want to fall back on
those principles don't break so many
principles next time and you know be
cautious and openings where you're
unfamiliar the next big thing is when
you're losing definitely be aware of
that and try to keep pieces on the board
try to create those threats I know this
is something you already know but you've
got to apply it at the board third of
all you've got to start calculating for
you to the ends until there's no more
threats on the board and you're certain
that you know the position has kind of
resolved that's when you're allowed to
stop calculating and lastly be aware of
your positional advantages your weak
squares and make sure you have a way to
use them don't throw away your pieces
that you were going to use to occupy
those weak squares and last but not
least don't be lazy at the
when you show up to our match I'm going
to be ready to play I'm gonna be full
throttle and I expect you two to do the
same with that in mind thank you all for
watching I think you're joining me here
this has been the road to 2000
specifically targeted at getting
Jonathan's trance to that expert level
for our match and I will see you next
time
you
[Music]
you